multiple fluffy cgi animals a failed
jump start into rom-com royalty an
uninspired biopic known for her role in
the big bang theory kaylee cuoco's
movies all have this one sad thing in
common keep watching to learn this
shocking truth in 2011 hollywood
capitalized on the popularity of kaley
cuoco by casting her in a lead role in a
tentpole release the live-action cgi
family easter movie hop the story of eb
a wisecracking rabbit and easter bunny
in training hop follows the talking
animal as he escapes to los angeles and
befriends two human allies in chill fred
o'hare played by james marsden and
fred's more driven sister sam o'hare
played by cuoco hop was a minor box
office hit raking in 108 million dollars
in north america meaning fewer people
bought a ticket to see cuoco on the big
screen than they did to watch her on the
big bang theory that year critical
assessment of hop was just as average
the film earned a pretty bad 24 score on
rotten tomatoes glenn heath jr of slant
wrote gone are the days of childlike
mystery and in their place we have the
childish hop philippa hawker of the age
wrote for the most part it tries too
hard lurching from one plot contrivance
to another and never giving any of its
cast much to do
a lot of biographical movies about
american musicians hit theaters in the
2000s many earning critical accolades
and awards attention including rey walk
the line and straight out of compton
there was one entry in the sub-genre
however that didn't knock film writers
and academy awards voters off their feet
the last ride a 2011 movie about the
last days of country music pioneer and
legend hank williams played by e.t star
henry thomas as he drives through the
midwest to play a couple of concerts in
late 1952 before he succumbs to the
fatal effects of alcoholism cuoco has a
small but pivotal role as a woman named
wanda with whom williams shares some
drinks and a brief ill-fated romance
with a thoroughly average 47 score on
rotten tomatoes the last ride is as of
2022 the best reviewed entry on cuoco's
cinematic resume mark olson of the los
angeles times wrote formally uninspired
and thematically weak the last ride
really goes nowhere
with a meager rotten tomato score of
seven percent the handful of critics who
even bothered to review authors
anonymous were in near universal
agreement that kaley cuoco's lightly
satirical indie comedy was a total dud
the 2014 movie co-starring 90s
heartthrob chris klein and tough guy
actor dennis farina is the worst
reviewed movie that cuoco has ever made
authors anonymous is a mockumentary
about a group of aspiring authors
together they experience jealousy
resentment and other negative emotions
when hannah played by cuoco the newest
writer to join the club becomes a wildly
famous and successful publishing
sensation almost immediately after
putting pen to paper that's despite
being an airhead who's never heard of
jane austen according to glenn kenney's
review for roger ebert dot com jane
on the tip of my tongue austin austin
austin like almost every other
publication and critic the aisle seat
panned authors anonymous but singled out
cuoco's performance as very good and
containing shrewd character work
kaylee cuoco was the romantic lead and
idealized crush object on the big bang
theory one of the most popular sitcoms
of the 2010s and all time so it was
something of a foregone conclusion that
she would star in a big screen movie in
the romantic comedy vein not unlike
friends breakout turned a-lister
jennifer aniston the wedding ringer
should have provided cuoco a jump start
into broad rom-coms and major movie
comedies but it didn't the film is
primarily a vehicle for broadway and
frozen co-star josh gatt who plays a
lovable nerd on the eve of marrying his
dream woman he has to recruit groomsmen
because he doesn't have any friends
placing him in weird situations with a
friend match service director played by
kevin hart despite the presence of the
usually bankable heart and a lot of
screen time from well-liked tv star
cuoco the wedding ringer underperformed
bringing in 64 million dollars in north
america reviews were just as so so as
the wedding ringer amassed a non-notable
29 rating on rotten tomatoes
2015's alvin and the chipmunks the road
chip would mark kaylie cuoco's last
major theatrical release before shifting
her focus back to tv this was the fourth
entry in the series of live-action cgi
movies starring the talking singing
rodents made famous by novelty records
in the 1950s and a saturday morning
cartoon show in the 1980s amidst a road
movie plot about the male chipmunks
trying to prevent their human caretaker
dave from marrying a doctor the singing
critters bond and battle with the
chippettes a trio of female chipmunks
who are also a sibling singing group amy
poehler voiced shy eleanor in alvin and
the chipmunks shipwrecked but opted not
to return for the road chip leaving the
role open for cuoco commercially the
road chip was a big success bringing in
234.8 million dollars at the global box
office film critics however found the
film to be utterly repulsive it scored a
lowly 15 on rotten tomatoes tara brady
of irish times wrote normally dependable
comic actors are wasted kath clark of
timeout recommended viewers quote stick
sharpened knitting needles into their
ears with reviews like that perhaps it's
a good thing that cuoco didn't show her
face in the movie represented only by
her barely recognizable pitch-shifted
vocal performance
regardless of her lack of critical
praise or abundant commercial film
success cuoco's fame has skyrocketed
since her role on season 1 of the hbo
max kaeper the flight attendant as well
as a lead voice role in the
well-received harley quinn animated
series she's also got a number of
opportunities in her future you didn't
make me joker i made myself with
multiple award-winning shows under her
belt the actress has proven that she is
a force to be reckoned with in the
entertainment industry in fact she has a
number of films lined up including the
netflix action comedy the man from
toronto and a rumored role in role play
per deadline of her upcoming romantic
comedy meet cute in which she stars
opposite snl comedian pete davidson
cuoco shared i saw the movie recently
and i'm so excited about it i'm trying
not to be biased but it's really sweet
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite actors are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]